eux ont bravé l'interdiction de
manifester ses rues ses milliers de
russes qui ont exprimé hier leur
opposition à la guerre menée par leur
président en ukraine l'opposant alexeï
navalni appelle d'ailleurs son peuple à
manifester tous les jours la russie où
les effets de certaines sanctions se
font déjà ressentir on va en parler avec
vous julie d'un gloss bonjour vous êtes
notre envoyé spécialà à mon champ sur
place beaucoup de boîtes américaine se
retire comme apple ses magasins en
centre ville sont fermés vous l'avez
constaté de vos propres yeux
oui un énormément d'entreprises
européennes ou américaines ont décidé de
quitter la russie vous avez vous l'avez
dit c'est le cas notamment d'apple de
fortes de nike ou encore et bien des
géants de l'aéronautique airbus ou
boeing ce qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences assez dramatique pour la
compagnie russe aeroflot qui possède 118
airbus et 59 boeing puisque cette
interdiction est bien concerne également
l'entretien ou encore les pièces
détachées beaucoup de l'entreprise
automobile décide également de quitter
la russie je suis allé dans le centre de
moscou dans un grand centre commercial
j'ai pu en effet voir que la boutique
apple était d'ores et déjà fermé il ya
plusieurs jours maintenant que les
personnes se ruaient sur les matériels
électroniques et notamment les iphone
d'apple apple qui a également affirmé
son apple store ici en russie son
application en ligne et l'application de
paiement à pulp et j'ai parlé avec pas
mal de gens dans ce centre commercial
est notamment beaucoup de jeunes qui me
disait que ce n'était que le début de
l'hémorragie mais qui ne souhaitait pas
céder à la panique et qu'il craignait
bien sûr que d'autres marques décide de
quitter le pays une autre une femme me
disait qu'elle était très inquiète mais
que pour elle il était déjà trop tard
pour quitter le pays que si elle avait
su elle aurait peut-être peut-être fait
j'ai pu m'entretenir également avec la
responsable d'une grande
entreprise qui possède plusieurs marques
de vêtements à bas prix et qui me disait
que d'un point de vue professionnel elle
était très inquiète pour son emploi et
pour l'emploi des centaines de personnes
qui travaillaient pour cette entreprise
européenne et que d'un point de vue
personnel elle avait peur d'un retour en
arrière du nantes d'une d'un pays où
elles n'auraient plus le choix de ce
qu'elle consomme de ce qu'elle regarde
ou encore des pays qu'elles qu'elles
dans lesquelles elle se rend ensuite
bien je suis allé dans le centre de
moscou parler avec des personnes plus
âgées parce qu'il faut bien se rendre
compte que bien la population russe est
plutôt coupée en deux entre ceux qui
soutiennent l'offensive russe et qui
soutiennent vladimir poutine ce sont
plutôt les personnes âgées et les jeunes
qui craignent ce retour en arrière dont
je vous parlais à l'instant et toutes
les personnes âgées avec lesquels j'ai
pu parler m'ont dit soutenir vladimir
poutine et qu'il serait prêt à manger du
pain s'il lui fallait se serrer la
ceinture et pour ceux julie qui ne
soutiennent pas vladimir poutine et la
guerre il faut faire preuve
d'imagination car les manifestations
sont interdites et les arrestations sans
chaînes
oui et tout à faire certaines personnes
bravent cette interdiction de
manifestation et ce fonds a quasiment
systématiquement arrêtés ce que nous
avons pu constater à moscou plus de sept
mille arrestations depuis le début de
l'offensive
ici en russie dont plus de trois
miliciens à moscou donc les gens font
preuve d'imagination pour tenter de
montrer leur opposition à ces deux
guerres on voit notamment des graffitis
sur les murs qui sont quasiment
systématiquement effacées ou encore des
panneaux qui sont aux fenêtres des
appartements avec marc et non à la
guerre c'est quasiment systématiquement
le même slogan il ya également et bien
des lettres ouvertes qui se multiplient
des lettres ouvertes d'étudiants par
exemple d'une prestigieuse université
qui forment diplomates ou encore cadre
des grandes entreprises qui ont donc 800
étudiants qui ont manifesté leur
opposition à la guerre dans le milieu
culturel également on voit de plus en
plus de voix s'élever contre cette
guerre mais un systématiquement et bien
il y à des représailles on pense
notamment à la directrice d'un théâtre
un bien qui s'est opposé à cette guerre
et qui a été renvoyé de son poste donc
beaucoup de gens tentent de se poser à
cette guerre une autre un autre fait
important c'est que par exemple des
personnes continuent à déposer des
fleurs devant l'ambassade d'ukraine à
aux couleurs de l'ukraine et fleurs
jaunes et bleu et il ya une image qui
choque beaucoup d'opposants ici bien
c'est notamment cinq enfants qui ont été
arrêtés alors qu'ils déposaient des
fleurs devant l'ambassade d'ukraine et
une photo circule beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux donc difficile de savoir
quelle est l'ampleur de ce mouvement de
procéder à ces quelle est l'ampleur de
ce mouvement d'opposition mais en tout
cas l'impression que ça donne c'est
qu'il grandit qu'il s'étend à
différentes sphères de la société malgré
les potentiels représailles julie dongle
of envoyé spécial de